you're right Jim 50% of the country is
getting a free lunch but nobody wants a
[ __ ] sandwich anymore I want to and
that's that's what you're getting in
terms of education health care and
retirement which are the three big
drivers those are the things we need to
attack and drive down and just overthrow
our closing panel are we Rome well
that's been the theme of course of the
whole four day freedom fest conference
here to find out what our panel things
please welcome back the founder of
Freedom Fest dr. marks casa
Marc all right ladies and gentlemen
going to put this book up here are we
roam like : Murphy like Ashlee invited
him to speak but you know he's
editor-at-large at Vanity Fair magazine
so Nick you know what that means he's
he's not to be found anywhere than rehab
yeah he's in rehab by the way we have
Nick Gillespie here and we're delighted
to have him up on the stage we're hoping
Senator Rand Paul will be joining us but
he has not appeared yet so we're having
Nick take his place certainly a welcome
addition to our panel and then we have
next to him Wayne Allyn root
now what did Rachel Madoff call you the
other night Oh Rachel Maddow Rachel
Maddow all right and pearl basically she
called me the most evil person in the
whole world so how let's have here you
have the most gay person in the world
yes sir yeah and Jenny Beth Martin from
Tea Party Patriots yes I imagine what
Rachel Maddow would be saying about you
who knows probably already has done so
and next to her we have the most
exciting personality at our conference
mr. Steve Forbes
wouldn't it be nice to say president of
the United States two times in a row and
next to him the man who would like to be
king Jim Rogers all right now since our
theme is are we Rome I thought I would
begin by testing some of these skills of
our distinguished panel to see how
knowledgeable they are on history so the
first one is a quote from Seneca now to
the elder Seneca the he's already
testing me isn't he senator well I just
think you tell me yeah I just exhausted
my knowledge of Glasgow Rome
well actually this quote probably
applies to you Nick more than anyone
else on the panel except maybe Jim
Rogers so we're gonna have both of you
can't comment on this quote there is no
great genius without a touch of madness
a touch a touch I have a lot more than a
touch I hope I think that quote was from
Joanne Skousen Oh could be should I go
on to the next quote yes alright so this
is a quote about inequality the fact
that inequality seems to be eternal
nothing can prevent some seats in the
theater from being better than others
that was definitely Kyra suppose I think
actually a Greek said that the Greek
theater and I think that kind of gets to
the question of fairness in life can I
suggest it also gets to a question of
technology we don't have to go to the
theater to experience drama or
entertainment and in the living room
actually which is where more and more of
the entertainment
ah nummy and the cultural economy is
taking place actually all the seats are
pretty good so just put an early marker
down that we're not room we're doing
much better because you can watch an
endless number of movies plays
information sources that were just
unimaginable and unattainable even 15
years ago on a big-screen TV for less
money than you ever had to pay for that
before you know and what and that's a
very good point yeah but but it's much
better to see it live at Freedom Fest
than to stay home and watch it oh good
point good point let's say I need to
give how many gold coins and you know
that's a good point some people come up
to us and say well why don't you have
live streaming we had a number of groups
coming you know we should have live
streaming so that so many more people
can enjoy this conference you know the
problem with that you're not here now
how many of you have felt that this
experience of Freedom Fest has meant a
lot more to you because you were here
than say a live streaming program
hey Jim feels that way especially
alright I'm I don't mean to you know I
guess because I'm speaking in place of
rand paul i want to immediately torn
turn towards pornography because I know
the senator would be talking about that
as well but to speak to Jim's point it's
true I mean it's a different experience
to be at something rather than watching
it so it's kind of similar it's the
difference between making love and
watching pornography hanging and we
should all be making love it down mental
Arcola you are speaking from experience
right you know well you know I try to
keep the porn days hidden but you know
it comes up see Wayne this is why we had
you kind of pushing we're having Nick on
the end instead of you so at the risk of
ending my political career I'm making a
statement I am NOT getting near the
topic of pornography
all right well Jenny Beth you haven't
said anything so far let's see here if
we can get a quote here for you that
we're in Vegas discussing this oh now to
get to something important all right how
about this and less money forms the
sinews of war
anybody know you said that Cicero
senior or junior there's only one kochia
okay all right so that's a very good
libertarian theme know anybody want to
comment on the war theme Jenny Beth
Martin are you pro war anti-war I think
that we all are for being able to live
without war and we understand that human
nature oftentimes results in war and in
differences of opinion mu you consider
yourself a conservative right a
conservative that would be if somebody
said what are you is the lighter of the
Tea Party Patriots I would say that I am
a constitutionalist okay our
Constitution very good but my mark mark
can I mention something Ron Allen root
please I may not be a fan of
or my name is war by the way Wayne Allyn
root but or what is it good for
absolutely nothing in this case
everything but I may not be a fan of war
but I'm very much a fan of the people of
fight war I love the military and one of
the things that makes America now
becoming Rome one of the things that
makes me sick to my stomach was if you
looked at the news last week we no
longer have the money to have fireworks
displays at military bases for the
families of our heroes we don't have the
money for swimming pools to be open for
the families of our heroes at military
bases and we don't have the money for
jet flyovers at military graduation
ceremonies but we have the money for our
Emperor Barack Obama to spend a hundred
million to go to Africa and on Barack
Obama Boulevard waved to his million
fans and pledged 7 billion of our money
to increase electricity access to
drumroll please
Africans what the hell has happened to
the United States of America wow I can
see wow Steve Forbes Steve Forbes you
have some good counsel on this tell us
what should we be honoring our military
no matter what if they're fighting a war
in Iraq that you are against or
Afghanistan that you think government
has gone too far should we be honoring
these men or should we treat them like
we did the Vietnam vets we just answered
the question we spat on the Vietnam vets
when was the people in Washington who
sent up there and that's the people who
deserve the scorn the people who sent
him there not those who went there
and and as NS for war
sometimes there aren't real differences
take our Revolutionary War I'm glad we
fought that one now do we have on our
panel a veteran at ah yeah yeah yeah yo
t am I the only one were you sure you
and enlisting or a draftee I think so I
was about to be drafted so I am this so
I could have my choice but I want to
tell you mark today I'm not the first to
say the first casualty of war is truth
there is no such thing in truth it's
truth when there's a war both sides lie
they make up huge lies they put huge
restrictions on their people they send
18 year old kids to kill each other
there's no such thing as good war in one
of my books I've written from and one
and one of the books I wrote for my
children I said to them if you're in a
country where that goes toward just get
out get out of there because both sides
are going to lie
you're going to be a victim of the war
and the politicians who are going to
destroy a lot of lives get out and go to
a neutral country because you look back
over the past what 20,000 wars in world
history I don't think anybody except
maybe Steve would say the American
Revolution is justified and maybe it is
but I'm saying there are very very very
few wars that anybody can defend 100
years later or 300
can I also add you know with all due
respect would Wayne was saying and I
agree actually with I think the
consensus of the panel that soldiers you
know soldiers deserve to be honored and
respected the generals and the
politicians who send young men and young
women to die too general especially for
no clear or compelling or important
reason as has been happening for the
entirety of the 21st century deserve our
scorn for sure there is always enough
money to fight wars and in fact in the
21st century alone the budget for the
Pentagon essentially doubled in nominal
terms and you
currently the u.s. spends about 47% of
all planetary expenditures on military
we can afford you know if the if the
Defense Department so wanted they could
afford to throw a couple of planes or
fireworks displays for the soldiers who
they say they exist for we are spending
far too much money on the military the
military is a bad investment there is no
military multiplier and we would do well
to get out of perpetual warfare state
but having said that I'm not I'm not
disagreeing with it because obviously I
think there's waste everywhere there's
plenty of waste at the Pentagon and we
should be cutting across the board but
here's some food for thought in the
history of the United States of America
every war combined I believe the numbers
we've spent seven trillion dollars for
the American Revolution - today the
number for the war on poverty the worst
war ever fought the most failing war
ever fought fifteen trillion dollars and
Counting it is a massive failure right
but didn't kill anybody
in the welfare program oh you kill their
families you destroyed their spirit you
gave them the ability to lie to apply to
tens of millions of lives and as Jenny
Beth made to the point of human nature
has not changed and if you're not
prepared to defend yourself others will
come after you even though it makes no
rational sense at all yeah and yeah and
I'm glad our grandfathers fought in
World War two I would rather have the
Stars and Stripes in the swastika thank
you very much so okay bye uh I this is
not like Jim's actual service of the my
father was in World War two he
participated the Normandy invasion and
fought throughout Western Europe and I
am very grateful for that sacrifice that
he and an entire generation made he also
told me that he would essentially break
my legs if I ever thought about
proactively engaging in war and I think
that's the right balance that we should
strike as a free nation
of free people so just buy that we're
kind of surveying our panel here to see
how down-to-earth you are how many of
you have had a friend or know someone
personally or dealt with anyone
personally on welfare how could you not
in America
everybody's on welfare you know
especially the libertarian movement it
seems it's privately funded welfare I
know I'm by the way it's important to
note as I mentioned in my opening speech
on Wednesday 101 million Americans
forget welfare forget disability forget
unemployment 101 million Americans are
on food assistance vs. 97 million that
actually work in the private sector the
numbers are mind-numbing everybody runs
into I mean you heard the numbers 101
million people that we all run into
people on welfare every day whether we
know it or not I'm not on welfare I wish
I could well I think to go to what's
Steve I think was getting at is human
nature doesn't change and you know if
you give people something for nothing
you're going to get more nothing and I
think one of the most troubling trends
in a broad sense for me again just
limiting to the 21st century is a
general decline in the workforce in the
labor force participation rate and the
reason why fewer people are choosing to
work is because they can and that you
know it doesn't mean that their costs of
their lives that goes away it just gets
shifted to other people it's a real
serious issue and we need to understand
to make sure that we don't demonize
people who are struggling and are
getting assistance whether it's publicly
or privately provided but we need to
change our way of thinking so that
everybody who can work is not only
working but as happy and as excited to
work in is in an economy where they can
actually grow and develop their talents
and in the best way possible
so
Jenny bath the Tea Party movement did it
get started in reaction to a bloated
welfare state a bloated warfare state
what were the issues and maybe we can
connect it to problems that that Rome
faced and its decline what what was it
that got you motivated to say wow I need
to get involved well it's a bloated
government period that started this
movement the stimulus bill in particular
was for for the modern-day Tea Party
movement
what made so many people so upset but
the stimulus was on top a tarp which was
on top of bailouts which was on top of
No Child Left Behind and Medicare Part D
mean the list goes on and on and on and
on
so it's out-of-control government
welfare and talking about the assistance
I I can talk about this in a way that
probably a lot of people cannot my
husband and I had a business in he well
he had the business and he was very very
successful for a while and in fact
employed 5,000 people and he wound up
ultimately losing everything and he had
signed personal guarantees so we wound
up having to file personal bankruptcy
because of this and this happened in
2008 and we lost everything and we
started over and we had to file
bankruptcy in America you're allowed
there's a system so when these things
happen you're allowed to to do this and
to start over and rebuild and that's
what we started working on literally two
or three weeks after we had filed our
bankruptcy had been finalized and we're
in the driveway of the house at a rental
house so we were looking at because we
knew we had to start over we get a phone
call from our mortgage company offering
us a Fannie Mae or Freddie Mac loan and
saying they can bring us up to speed on
our mortgage and then we could stay in
it we can afford the house anymore
who in the right
I give somebody who just came out of
bankruptcy free a free loan our federal
government this is a huge problem we we
turned it down and when we turn that
down it was completely a private
decision I never knew I would be on
national TV or in a room full of
thousands of people discussing it but we
did it because we're so opposed to tarp
and in America I am NOT opposed to
safety nets and when you you're worrying
about how you're going to put food on
your family for your children you cannot
understand the real fear and concern
people have and when there's a safety
net there so it it relieves it relieves
some people's anxiety for us we knew we
had succeeded and we knew we could start
over and do it again and it just it's
it's we have to have compassion and we
had compassion from our friends and we
had compassion privately and we we did
what it took to start over now Jim
Rogers thank you thank you is Jim Rogers
is what Jenni Beth told you totally
foreign to your way of thinking once you
are expatriate representative here and
expat as we would always call them and
you live in Singapore your resident of
of Asia does this says it's totally
foreign to you is this why one of the
reasons you left the United States
because of the craziness of our laws
well I still have an American taxpayer
and her American voter an American
citizen you cannot escape the IRS no
matter where you go no matter how hard
you try unless you want to risk going to
jail so yes I live outside but isn't it
still legal for Americans to live what
they want to we become North Korea we
become Cuba are we not allowed to live
where we want yes I live abroad but and
as I look at America from abroad I I'm
not happy with what I see of course
that's one reason that I wanted my
children to grow up in Asia I want my
children to know Asia because the 21st
century is the century of Asia Rome is
in decline and
Asia's on the rise I want my children to
speak Mandarin and they do speak matter
because that in their lifetimes will be
very very important you know China the
largest creditor nations in the world
are China Korea Japan Taiwan Hong Kong
Singapore the assets are in in Asia you
know where the debts are you can look
out the window and see the debts America
is the largest debtor nation in the
history of the world even Rome at its
worst never got so deep in debt as we
have gotten in this in this country
partly because of what we just heard
we've heard about this during this panel
and it's getting worse mark I mean I the
title of this panel is are we Rome
we've already outdone Rome we're we're
declining much faster than Rome did
because we have an unlimited printing
press and if anybody needs a handout we
give them a handout
even in Rome at its worst they never did
that and Steve Forbes you do a big
conference every year in Asia you know
I'm sure you don't spend all four days
like you spend at Freedom Fest but no
I'm sure you do at your conference in
Asia so why do you have a conference in
Asia is there something special about
Asia that you think the West is in
decline like Rome and so age' is the
place to be and when are you planning to
move to Singapore
we're heavily involved in Asia because
it's a huge opportunity especially with
the what the row of Chinese did in 1978
finally getting back to modernization
which was interrupted by the Japanese
invasion in 1937 dong made the change
profoundly impressed by what happened in
Singapore Lee Kuan used the hero of
modern Asia he showed the way as did the
Japanese in their own way it becomes
stuck in recent times but Asia is a very
dynamic area you'd be a fool to ignore
it but I think and Europe is partially
hopeless but I have hope because of
Central and Eastern Europe and here in
the United States I think we
underestimate our ability to regenerate
you could make a case in the 30s
especially when we passed the National
Recovery administration Act the most
fascist thing we ever did in this
country we had a Supreme Court that
acted constitutionally then but the
1970s were a horrific decade we forget
that that's been expunged from the
memory because the Liberals caused it so
they have no ax desire to bring that
disaster up again and so I think you're
going to start to see it again the Tea
Party was suppressed in 2012 now we know
it
Charles Murray's doing a book on the
overreach in a very systematic way of
the government and the hideous police
things they're doing when that
information becomes aggregated that's
going to cause a profound change in
public opinion
George Gilders got a book out that I
think revolutionizes economics so we're
setting the foundation both in terms of
theory and knowledge and self-awareness
and also in action combining theory and
action
raising as the Marxist would say
consciousness you're going to see a
profound change in the next four to five
years I think we're going to be
pleasantly surprised at how quickly
we're going to turn start to turn this
thing around most people don't like
where we are today maybe so so Jim I see
I assume that you have now been
convinced by the great wisdom of Steve
Forbes and you are now noting an
optimist nothing would make me happier
than what Steve just said but I would
remind all of you that in the 30s and in
the 70s America was a creditor nation in
fact the largest creditor nation in the
world by the 70s but now we're the
largest debtor nation in the history of
the world as recently as 1987 we were
still a creditor nation that's only 26
years ago and the debts are going higher
and higher and higher no country in
world history that's gotten itself into
this kind of situation has gotten itself
out without a crisis or a semi crisis
but I hope that Steve's right now I'm
wrong
well what when one of the nice things is
while we have a lot of liabilities we
still are a nation with immense assets
household wealth in this country is over
sixty five trillion dollars and I think
that's a good foundation how did we get
out of the mess of the 70s we did it by
increasing the asset side of the
nation's balance sheet
even though Reagan spent a lot of money
on the military our debt to more than
doubled in the 70s but we won the Cold
War I mean in the 80s but even though
the debt went up one point seven
trillion when they went a trillion was
real money the way that the net the net
wealth of the nation went up seventeen
trillion and so we'll release the
dynamism of the American people and
we'll get out of these debts and
unfunded liabilities in health care you
get some real free enterprise in health
care those unfunded liabilities come
crashing down
the Wayne Allyn root are you an optimist
or a pessimist well I'm a little bit of
both I'm an optimist and pessimist I I
agree in love steve forbes i disagree
with what's going to happen i agree
there's one way out of the mess things
were almost as bad as now under Jimmy
Carter in comes Ronald Reagan massive
tax cuts but the inflation is nowhere
near agree but we're from the 70% range
of taxes under Reagan to the 28% range
what did that mean
he didn't reward poor people he didn't
reward people that wanted welfare the
rewards went to small business owners if
you pay the taxes you create the jobs
that's who you've got a reward so where
I agree with Stephens we could turn this
around tomorrow if we replicated the
Hong Kong economy with a 15% flat tax
keep your mortgage deduction keep your
charitable deduction keep your business
deduction 0% capital gains tax we turn
around this company on a dime this
country on a dime tomorrow
Hong Kong right now greatest economy of
the world booming three point five
percent unemployment but we're not going
to do that
we've got Obama as president and it's
not going to happen and as a great man I
know named Mark Skousen once wrote how
do canada turn it around they cut
spending dramatically and cut taxes
dramatically you've got to reward the
job creators and that small business and
this country will not do that with
Barack Obama as president United States
yeah thank thank you thank you I was
gonna say I don't necessarily disagree
with that but I also think you know part
of getting out of a problem is
diagnosing it properly
everything that Barack Obama is doing he
is basically inheriting and extending
George Bush's policies and the policies
of a full-blown Republican government
it's really important to know that
including tarp tarp last time I checked
was a bush disaster not an Obama one not
that Obama you know turned that around
or anything the Republican Party and I
think conservatives in America one of
the things we have to understand and
this is something that Matt Welch and I
talked about earlier this morning is
when you have the state grow so large
that there is no escaping it unless you
go just Singapore and as Jim was saying
he's still paying he's still on the hook
for the American tax but
I guess what you buy by leaving the
country is you're not responsible for
the damage we do but you're still
getting the check right or at least your
portion of it but we need to understand
that we need a rescission and not a
return to Reagan because Reagan did
Reagan is the apostle of deficit
spending there is no way around that
what we need is a government that lives
within its means it did not under Ronald
Reagan debt went up what we need now is
a government that spends less and does
less and allows the ultimate human
resource which is individuals and the
groups they form in the companies they
form to move forward into the future
Steve Steve did you want to did Regan
justified the deficit because he was
dealing with heavily dominated
Democratic Congress or is he should he
be blamed for the for never presenting a
balanced budget in eight years running
for running the country well there you
can balance a budget by increasing taxes
a lot and I think we have to remember
what Milton Friedman said he would
rather have a two trillion dollar at one
trillion dollar budget this is obviously
old a one trillion dollar budget that
was badly out of balance than two
trillion dollar budget imbalance because
government is claiming a lot of
resources so we've got to avoid that
trap but again the key thing is for this
country's to liberate the mind and it's
already beginning with George Gilders
book bringing together knowledge and
economics what charles murray is doing
in terms of the catastrophic overreach
of government government is and we
should listen to Murray government is
going to be its own enemy why because
it's such a muscle-bound Leviathan we're
going to be starting to practice Jennie
better than others going to jujitsu
on it and we're going to turn that thing
right upside down and the way you attack
government is not piece by piece like
trench warfare you start with the big
stuff start with the tax code huge
source of power start with health care
huge source of power
start with liberating education which
the web will help you do you take the
government out of health
taxation you have private social
security counts you have these a basic
fundamental reforms that most people
will applaud because it gives them
cheaper health care and the like because
entrepreneurs are let loose you start to
really whack the Leviathan and you don't
get in the trap the Republicans got in
the mid-nineties of fighting trench
warfare where you get shot up gained a
few yards and then lose it again and the
combination again of theory and action
is going to be very very potent Adam
Smith did it in the late 1700s Thomas
Paine did it a lot of theories out there
they brought it together and the result
was a positive revolution but Steve
everybody in this everybody in this old
on everybody in this room would agree
with you and vote for that policy but in
America more than 50% of the people get
a free lunch you think they're gonna
vote to have the free lunch taken away
from them I'll tell you what most
Americans will still vote for
opportunity and one reason we got
shellacked in 2012 is we didn't have
candidates starting at the top who
advocated we're at what we're advocating
here right don't advocate I travel when
I can just to bring some body language
in you're right Jim 50% of the country
is getting a free lunch but nobody wants
a [ __ ] sandwich anymore
I want to and that's that's not you're
getting in terms of education health
care and retirement which are the three
big drivers those are the things we need
to attack and drive down and just
overthrow hey mark just one sentence
literally I'm losing one of his panel y
sense it's not getting better folks from
from January 1st to March 31st 1/4 three
months 6118 new regulations under the
Obama administration that's 68 a day and
then since then it's gone to 72 a day
I'm a small businessman there's no way
to run a successful business in the
United States of America anymore under
Barack Obama that just can't do it
that's a perfect introduction to the
next quote the more corrupt the
Commonwealth the more numerous the laws
by Tacitus and as you know each year at
Freedom Fest we have a theme I
theme this year's are we Rome I think
we've done a great job of covering this
next year we've come up with a theme
that I think you will all find
interesting and we have a now a short
video to anticipate what we're going to
be doing next year if you can play the
video
you
well I think that are we wrong really
resonated with the attendees at Freedom
Fest we had a Huey 2200 people attending
plus all of those who came to the
stossel show and with this theme
disappeared on us but the is Big Brother
here I think it also will resonate with
the American people and people
everywhere because you can see and Big
Brother isn't just watching you he's
taxing you
he's regulating you he's depreciating
your currency he is slowly strangling
our freedom so we've got to fight back
and that is going to be our theme next
year at Freedom Fest and we're very
excited about it
so Jenny Beth would you like to respond
to our video for next year our theme you
know groups with Tea Party and Patriots
have been targeted by the government in
the IRS our organization Tea Party
Patriots in the last eight weeks has
been on the front lines watching these
things unfold and seeing the truly
silencing effect that it has had
citizens are afraid to speak out they've
silenced us they did what they could to
suppress us in 2012 and it's been very
very it's frightening to see this happen
in our country where we're supposed to
be free you said that the more corrupt
the more numerous the laws and I want to
say two things that and something that
Steve Forbes said the Steve said to go
back to the root of the problem and go
to the principle and attack the big the
big thing our tax code since the 1980s
we've had three three taxpayer Bill of
Rights and those three taxpayer Bill of
Rights did nothing at all to
checked the Bill of Rights noting our
tax code is over 73,000 pages long
there's no way anyone the IRS doesn't
even know what's in those 73,000 pages
it's insane and so Steve also said
theory in action together raised
consciousness and people can can take
action I think that's why we were
targeted
not just Tea Party Patriots but nine
twelve groups and groups that we're
studying the Constitution we want a
better country because we figured out
the trick in the solution and the reason
we maybe Rome but I have hope for
America and that's why I'm fighting
because our principles and the
principles that made this country great
will continue to sustain us and make us
great and greater in the future as long
as we understand what those principles
are and the people in this modern day
Liberty movement that's what we are
doing we're teaching people about the
principles of the Constitution and about
freedom in the fact that DC or central
government wherever it is doesn't have
to have all this control and we
threatened them and we're going to
continue to do it and we're going to
continue to fight for freedom and
because of that we're not going to be
room we're going to be America thank you
very much thank you Steve and more mark
and more you will now have Jim Rogers
the last word for our panel no not well
I'm sorry I want to let I would change
the title not his big brother here - big
brother is here and I would reserve a
section for him to come because he's
here hey Mark mark mark you're being
you're being politically incorrect you
should have big sister too
oh we were gonna have some trouble well
you know a lot of us a lot of people
came and criticized our title are we
Rome saying no we are Rome but we like
to put it in the terms of a question
mark we want to debate on this because
there are arguments on the other side of
these issues that saying no it's not big
brother it's something else I don't know
what it is but it is but there are
arguments here and so we always like to
put it in the form of a question mark so
that we can we can debate these subjects
and so forth hey mom
mark can I jump in I wanted to I wanted
to jump in on Jenny's IRS point because
I think that that Jenny and the Tea
Party groups need to understand that it
wasn't Tea Party groups only that were
ordered it was individual critics across
the United States I've been the subject
of two vicious IRS audits won them both
but not without a cost of tens of
thousands of dollars to prove my
innocence and I think there were critics
all over this country and the goal of
this administration is not just to shut
down tea parties but if you speak out
they want to destroy you they want to
intimidate you they want to bleed you
dry with legal fees accounting fees and
they assume they'll find something that
you'll owe and suddenly there's no money
left to give to conservative causes and
GOP donors as well and then the last
point I wanted to make was you keep
saying are we Rome looking back to the
old Rome the average American gets an F
in history they don't know about it they
don't want to know about it they don't
care about it it's better to compare us
to Rome today we are today's Italy
today's Greece
today's Spain today's Portugal today's
France we are bankrupt they are bankrupt
all right well
I think you can turn it around just like
Canada did it just takes leadership and
that's what we lack in this country and
as far as getting audited by the IRS
we're going to have a whole session next
year on the obi-wan kenobe method of
aborting the IRS you do not need to
audit me oh we will not audit them
that's what you need the OB like you
know I use it when I go through security
you do not need to check this person let
this person anyway we'll have a lot of
fun with this next year and I hope you
all will join us I did want to mention a
couple of other things that we want to
do here we want to have our raffle as
you know we're giving away for two
individuals get to come to Freedom Fest
next year and have their expenses paid
for I don't know all the benefits but it
really and we had a lot of people sign
up for it so we're gonna draw a spell
errata fits Barack Obama and Janet
Napolitano well if they're in there I
don't see if we can get them we do have
our conference in the Bahamas which this
year next year is February 6 through the
9th is called the world financial forum
a summit sorry and it is meant to be the
anti Davos conference they meet in
freezing Switzerland we meet in the
balmy the Bahamas we offer free market
solutions to the world problems so we're
trying to build this event in February
in the Bahamas as the alternative to
Davos the world forum that they have in
Davos we're also doing a cruise we know
a lot of people are interested in our
cruise it is starting in Singapore where
Jim Rogers lives and then goes to
Vietnam up to Hong Kong Taiwan and Japan
and you can take side excursions to
China if you wish but we've had a lot of
interest in that so stop by the
registration
and ask if you're interested regarding
the video that you just saw that will be
showing throughout the year we will be
posting that and you can send it to all
of your friends starting next week and
we hope you will spread the word I think
it's a really powerful video describing
what our country faces the other thing I
want to mention was that a lot of work
and effort has been put together at the
staff and normally at our Saturday night
banquet we thank all our staff but not
all of you come to the banquet so when
you get a chance please stop by the
registration area and give a big thanks
to Tammy Holland and her staff the work
that they put through my wife Joanne in
the anthem film festival let's give them
a big round of applause right now for
everything they did to put this oh great
another announcement Jim Rogers has just
informed me that lazy Fair Books has I
think a couple hundred more copies of of
street smarts Jim Rogers book I think
you mentioned that before that it is
available what time is the signing do
you know now at 3:20 and as I said
before street smarts is in my opinion
and it's not just my opinion many people
feel this is Jim Rogers best book it's
just a wonderful description of the
current state of affairs and his unique
perspective his unique perspective on
what's going on in the world and Asia
and the West and so forth and he tells
some great stories I highly recommend
that
finally the CDs are available not only
for this conference but we have the best
of Freedom Fest if you would like to
pick that up see Harold over and her and
his children and wife and so forth
they're all involved over there so pick
that up before you leave or sign up for
it and it would be sent to you I think
I've covered everything
except the drawing and then once we do
the drawing I guess we can do that right
now but right after the drawing we're
going to pull this stuff these things
down we're going to have a picture with
all of our in anybody who has a silver
dollar come on up we're going to have
our picture taken together I know it's
difficult to get the silver dollar but
for those who have them bring it up here
show your silver dollar we're going to
take a picture and we'll put that on the
web to represent our symbol for liberty
and sound money okay so now we're going
to ask Jenny Beth to do the drawing and
I'll give one more turn of this remember
you have to be here to win I'll do it
again real quick
the winner gets tickets to next year's
Freedom Fest 4 nights in the hotel VIP
seats at our closing banquet and a
gorgeous 1 ounce gold coin an 1874
beautiful 1 ounce gold coin so with that
reach in there screw tomorrow have to be
here Bob Lynch from Seattle Washington
are you here ok come on up
congratulations congratulations all
right fantastic okay